it's survival of the fittest and you've
been transported into a real life death
game where everyone has superpowers
including you and the only way to escape
the game is to kill or die what do you
do i'm going to break down the mistakes
made what you should do and how to be
the death game in darwin's game conomy
is chilling at school when he receives a
text from a friend inviting him to play
a free to play game on his phone called
darwin's game before anyone can say
anything he clicks on the game only to
find a snake magically come out of the
phone to bite him causing him to pass
out later at the school nurse's office
he says he's not feeling too good and
decides to head home on the train he
checks out darwin's game a second time
and accidentally begins a match with a
man dressed in a panda costume all of a
sudden that very same panda man in real
life comes towards him and tries to kill
him forcing kaname to get off the train
and run for his dear life with no one to
help and kaname in a dead end he says
his prayers until his best friend saves
him just in the nick of time getting
hurt in the process he and the injured
best friend hide from panda man when we
learned that darwin's game is actually
real and that there are a few rules to
this game we can't call emergency
services during the game we can only
contact the outside world through the
phone app itself and that our general
location can become visible to the enemy
when we use our phones during a match
and that sucks for konami because he
accidentally reveals his location to
panda man when he checks a mysterious
text he receives from an unknown girl
this causes panda man to comfort their
throats and forces kaname to learn the
most important rule of all that in order
to survive we either need to hide until
the timer runs out or take out our
opponent by sheer luck and a little bit
of skill but mostly luck economy
survives and beats panda man but also
loses his best friend in the process
man and here i thought the only thing
pandas could harm were piles of bamboo
kaname had the right idea but executed
it poorly we should have used the
environment to our advantage more and
ran head first into crowded areas like
busy streets or nearby malls this may
not have stopped panda man but the more
people he has to kill in order to get to
me might cause enough of the public to
panic to where i can either blend in
with the fleeing crowds or be saved by
nearby on-duty police officers if the
route forbids me from finding any nearby
populated areas then instead of politely
panicking to nearby officers i would
take a swing at them and steal their
sidearm piece to defend myself as it's
obvious from the encounter economy has
with that police officer that he's
packing heat now our friend showing up
was a welcome addition but he's losing
blood and is now officially a waste of
space no offense so i'd say let's leave
him and find some nearby drinks from
either a vending machine or nearby store
along with a fire extinguisher having
the bottles of liquids will allow us to
stop padman's camouflage ability by
splashing him with the stuff allowing us
to see the now wet outline of his body
and the footprints to go along with it
or if [ __ ] hits the fan like now and
thanks to that cop panda man is now
armed and invisible so our safest play
will be the fire extinguisher which we
can use by hiding behind a door or an
empty room with only one exit wait until
the door opens by itself and then blast
him in the face with some good old co2
temporarily blinding his vision allowing
us to knock him out with the fire
extinguisher itself and then smashing
his brains in back at home conomy
realizes he can order weapons straight
from the online store within the app as
a pistol magically appears at his door
out of thin air perfect timing as he
receives a text from that mysterious
girl from before who asks him to come to
meet her in exchange for information
about darwin's game itself connie then
heads to an abandoned warehouse where he
meets a girl named shuka who tells him
that she'll spill the beans only if he
proves he's trustworthy by showing her
his superpower or sigil as they call it
which are superpowers that each member
in darwin's game randomly gets when they
join which could be anything bad news
for kaname though as he doesn't know
what the hell she's talking about which
angers shuka and causes her to challenge
kaname to a death match although good
thing for kaname and his quick thinking
as he blinds shuka with a self-defense
flashlight and makes a break for it in
the process we also get to see what
chuka's powers are as she terrifyingly
chases economy around the warehouse that
is until he somehow unlocks his signal
which turns out to be the very same
pistol he got earlier creating it from
his hands out of thin air thanks to
kaname and his smarts he manages to
defeat shuka and win the match and he
decides to spare her life which is
technically not against the rules
unfortunately for him all of this
superpower stuff wears kaname down and
he passes out right after
this girl is a firecracker and downright
terrifying and awfully rude so therefore
she must die konami finally revealed his
signal which looks like the m9 beretta
firearm he ordered from earlier and from
shuka's speed she seems to be able to
dodge anything we fire at her this means
to close the gap between us our bullet
and her sweet face we need to blind her
or surprise her because this will ensure
she will be unable to effectively dodge
our attacks i would cut the power the
same way economy did except hide between
the boxes and cargo within the warehouse
forcing shuka to come closer towards us
her being blinded will result in her
being unable to know from which
direction the bullet comes from and
therefore will be unable to use her
super quick reflexes to dodge it and we
only need one well-timed shot so i say
let's empty the mag into the girl and
see what happens later konami wakes up
to anna
revealing shuka who convinces konami to
start a clan with her within the game
joining forces basically as they head
for a walk she reveals to kaname more
information about the game winning
matches gives you points that you can
use to spend on safe shelters food
weapons and real life cash although you
cannot talk about darwin's game in
public or risk being teleported from the
game during their timeout kaneme's phone
also gets stolen by a young
spikey-haired guy who also informs us
that we can't play the game with someone
else's phone although our phone can get
destroyed by anyone meaning if that
happens this would result in the player
being unable to buy or seek safe shelter
as well as never know when they're being
battled they also wouldn't be able to
search or communicate through text or
call with anyone leaving them isolated
you'd basically be royally screwed but
thankfully this thief has got some
manners as spiky-haired guy challenges
kaname the good old-fashioned way with a
death match and of course konami like
before stumbles along getting lucky
right at the end yet again by using his
last minute circle to stun spiky-haired
guy almost destroying his phone and
winning the match right before they are
teleported to join an event known as the
treasure hunt game okay spiky-haired guy
is young and ambitious i'll give him
that and let's thank him for not using
his single powers on us because this
just makes it that much easier since we
can't rely on our single powers to work
effectively we must rely on our body's
anatomy namely our fists and his groin
softer areas like the throat eyes and
groin work wonders for most people if
you hit them hard enough and i'm willing
to bet my career that it'll work on this
teenage punk i'm going to focus on
closing the gap between us and spiky
hair dude therefore we should consider
getting punched a couple of times
forcing spike hair dude to enter our
arm's lengths to keep him distracted and
be within our striking distance then
right after i would aim for a shot
straight to his money makers as hard as
i can with an uppercut to his nether
regions using our legs would be
preferable and would allow us to drive
more force towards the area then aim for
the area between spider hair dude's
belly button and johnson as this will
almost certainly cause him to hunch
forward whether it's for a brief second
or for longer likely causing him to fall
over if he's weak enough then we can use
our signal as well and then i tase him
repeatedly for good measure then crush
his throat with my foot what there's no
rules in fight club kaname suddenly
appears at a hotel just in time for the
treasure hunt game as he gets
instructions on the game itself find the
hidden treasure located around shibuya
and get as many points as possible
within the 24 hour limit killing players
while in the game will not grant you any
death match points and all players must
collect at least three rings before the
game ends or they die kaname running out
of the room bumps into machine gun guy
as he gets hunted around the hotel floor
trapped as the only way out is through
the elevators kaname finally gets
cornered and is forced to give up
whatever rings he has on him and machine
gun guy lets him live and leaves in the
elevator right after he meets smart girl
who tells him that the elevator is a
trap set up by someone we'll call plant
guy because he has planned powers and
smart girls suggests that they team up
in order to survive and kaname agrees we
also learn smart girl's power is the
ability to know the location and
movement of all matter in the world
which means she can basically dodge
anything that comes at her or fire any
gun and know the movement of the bullet
one hundred percent suddenly they run
into machine gun guy again and other
gang members who look to be under plant
guys mind control as they begin to chase
down kaname and smart girl both of them
try to hide and destroy all the hotel
floor cameras as they have a feeling
plant guy is watching and they managed
to hide in a hotel room as the two are
hunted down relentlessly by plant guys
minions conomy and smart girl hatch a
plan and order some grenades off the
phone's in-game app and then begin
getting to work smart girl distracts the
minions with an explosion as kaname uses
the fire extinguisher rope in the hotel
hallway to climb down past the floor set
with plant guys traps and he reaches the
bottom floor safely i'm starting to like
smart girl and she seems like a valuable
member to have in terms of information
gathering and reconnaissance although
she kinda dropped the ball here a little
bit i would use the in-game shop to
order me a box of 12 grenades two
flashbangs and two ropes if we can have
things delivered straight to our feet
almost magically we should have used the
in-game store more effectively we could
have explored more what the in-game shop
had to offer and perhaps have bought
other items that could have helped us in
this situation there's nowhere to go and
machine gun guy here seems to be packing
the biggest weapon sporting a russian
rpd light machine gun and those things
don't mess around so we really can't
fight them head on effectively so once
again the element of surprise will be
our biggest edge i would plant a box of
six grenades minus one for us as we
plant one box in the corner of each of
the hotel's two staircases where we know
plant guys minions will be coming from
then i'd have conomie to camp out on one
staircase while having smart girl camp
out on the other one once the two
minions come down between each of the
staircases i toss a flashbang blinding
them then toss a single grenade towards
each of the two boxes catching the
minions by surprise and setting off a
massive chain explosion within each of
the hotel staircases killing all of the
minions in the process afterward all we
need to do is simply rappel down the
window with our ropes no fuss kaname on
the ground floor suddenly runs into
plant guy and has no choice but to
battle him face to face this is when he
realizes that unless he does something
different he will soon die as plant guy
clearly outranks him in power and
endurance but all of a sudden he locks
out as he discovers a new trick to his
single power which is if he cuts his
weapon's lifespan shorter he can
effectively increase the internal
pressure of his bullet rounds increasing
their firepower by an additional 10
percent this 10 increase in power proves
to be effective as konami manages to
break through plant guy's shield and
defeats another opponent yet again this
time with a little less luck and a
little more skill alright we finally
learned how to control our powers and
figured out some tricks now we're pretty
much cornered and unmatched so i think
the safest option would be to uh run
konami has been using his powers for a
while and he has already stated that
he's exhausted so realistically i doubt
we'd have enough endurance to keep going
on for much longer which is why we need
some space and time to think i would
hide within one of the many hiding spots
in the hotel then i would load up on
items such as grenades flashbangs even a
knife although i would see if we could
use our power to create them all at once
but if this doesn't work then during our
few moments of peace and quiet i would
use my time to check the in-game app
store and see just what else we could
get and if we could find specialty
ammunition our rpd machine gun uses 762
ammunition so i would look in the store
for specialty rounds like high explosive
incendiary rounds or even an actual full
metal jacket round designed to pierce
through and take out plant guy's armor
checkmate buddy after the match economy
decides to keep plant man alive him and
smartgo recruit him and machine gun guy
from earlier to form an alliance as
there's a rumor that an even bigger
threat will be coming to the hotel very
soon namely the famous and ruthless 8th
clan who are looking to win darwin's
game and kill whoever and however many
people it takes to achieve their goals
kaname along with machine gun guy then
head off to find shuka who sends them a
mysterious help text from the subway on
the way there they run into a tiny
little human who has ice powers we'll
call her elsa and kaname dives into the
waterfield subway to find a hopeless
shuka once saved they find out that it
was that strange little girl elsa who
trapped shuka and thanks to elsa's split
personality she has two powers as part
of her signal one being her power to
manipulate bodies of water and the other
the power of ice luckily for elsa shuka
decides to show some mercy because of
her split personality and spare elsa's
life for almost killing her and so they
end up recruiting her into their
alliance just as they find out from
smart girl that the rings everybody's
collecting are not the real treasure so
economy and the group set off to find
smart girl along with the real treasure
while plant guy stays behind at the
hotel to take on part of the 8th clan
but as their bad luck would have it they
reached the subway only to find that
smart goal has been taken hostage by
some of the members of the 8th clan
wasting no time conomy and his group
battle out eighth clan as shuka save
smart girl who then goes to try and
locate the real treasure sadly for
machine gun guy during the battle his
hand gets chopped off by the leader of
the eighth clan dreadlocks guy kaname is
then forced to bluff his way into saving
him just as he thanks to smart girl
finds the real treasure in a locker room
right next to everybody this results in
kaname in his group winning the match
and saving machine gun guy as the
treasure hunt game officially ends now
in this situation we finally have our
team of superheroes and so this is where
some better leadership from kaname would
have come in handy for one our group
should not be split up entirely but
rather have taken cover nearby as one
unit i then ordered smart girl to place
her sights on dreadlock sky from a
distance and wait for my orders
dreadlock guy's teleportation powers
make him fast and nimble and so we want
to try and injure him or prevent him
from teleporting altogether first before
taking him out in this case our biggest
powerhouse believe it or not is elsa as
she's one of the few who can take on
dreadlocks guy head on i would order
shuka to take out the majority of grunts
with her powers as she does so with ease
then i'd have elsa get her water from
the nearby train bathrooms to take out
the rest of the henchmen from here we
have two options one elsa floods the
metro and takes out everybody including
dreadlocks guy elsa would need to create
a sphere wall made of water around
dreadlock sky up to 20 meters thick in
width and height preventing dreadlocks
guy's teleportation abilities from
teleporting him out of the water prison
as we have seen from his attacks the
furthest dreadlocks guy can teleport is
up to 10 meters so if our water sphere
is larger in width and height then we
could effectively capture him i would
then scare the [ __ ] out of elsa and have
her evil twin come out to play and turn
that entire sphere of water into a giant
ice ball prison freezing and capturing
dreadlocks guy entirely the second
option would be to have elsa take out
the henchmen and dreadlocks guy with a
giant wave of water filling up the
subway then like a wave on a beach wash
dreadlocks guy right up near smart girl
and she takes him out with her bolt
action sniper rifle the confusion from
being tossed around from a giant water
wave and overwhelmed should be enough to
distract dreadlocks guy from teleporting
for at least a few seconds which we can
use to our advantage and kill him two
months later after the competition
kaname uses his connections and prize
money to get himself in shape by
training with another group called the
dan zhao boxing club where they train
kaname and surgically fix machine gun
guy's hand this is also when kaname
looks into making an alliance with the
club itself however the leader of danjah
boxing club mr muscles says that he must
first fight kanye to see if he's worthy
of forming an alliance with kaname
follows his wishes and challenges him to
a friendly match but of course mr
muscles doesn't take it easy on kaname
and almost beats him without even using
his single power but luckily economy
narrowly defeats mr muscles winning the
match and successfully securing an
alliance with the don zhao boxing club
hey i like mr muscles he's arguably one
of the best opponents in the game and
someone i definitely don't want to mess
with but since we have to i would have
liked to end the match sooner than
conowy did by cheating a little bit i
would have used the time before the
match to excuse myself to the restroom
to order a little bit of everything from
the in-game shop like grenades
flashbangs flamethrowers whatever i can
get my hands on this way we could have
saved up all of our single power for the
match as even before the match started
it's obvious we're going to need all of
our strengths since we last saw kaname
he has definitely picked up some moves
and if we take inventory we now have
knives grenades flashbangs an rpd
machine gun an m9 pistol and a machete
and even a scorpion submachine gun that
is freaking awesome although i would
have begun the match by attacking mr
muscles with any one of my guns i would
have waited like kaname did until i
tricked mr muscles into revealing to me
his power with a grenade i would have
then as my last trick halved my firearms
lifespan in order to increase my power
output by 10 percent like kanema did
with plant guy earlier this would have
either taken mr muscles completely out
or forced him to use his power to defend
himself if this happened then i would
have used this brief moment to flash
bang him and then close the distance
with my machete to his throat as of this
point we've only attacked him from afar
up until now and maybe we could stab his
eye if we can't cut through his flesh
and at least blind him a little bit
konami's victory is suddenly cut short
as long hair girl shows up just in the
nick of time to knock everybody out and
kidnaps kaname later he wakes up in the
limo of the long-haired girl darwin's
game's number one player who we find out
is part of a family of generational
assassins scared kaname has little
choice until we find out that shuka and
konami's clan follow close by on
kaname's tale fearful for their lives he
makes a deal with long-haired girl the
deal being if she can successfully
escape from them without killing anyone
the economy will do as she requests
thankfully this kid's got himself a good
teammate ashoka calls upon long-haired
girl and they battle it out on the roof
of their cars along with the rest of
kaname's team as they manage to stop
long-haired girl's car in time making
this terrifying assassin lose the bet
against kaname forcing long-heard girl
to join forces with them there was no
reason to fight as long as they did when
the entire wager of kaname's bet with
long-haired girl rested on their
transportation if we stop long-haired
girl's car from driving away then how
will she escape and if she doesn't
manage to successfully escape then that
means we'd win the bet so this really
means this whole time that they should
have been focusing on the tires of her
car almost exclusively as shuka battles
it out with long-haired girl and keeps
her distracted i would order smart girl
to take position with her sniper rifle
atop the roof of their humvee and then
using smart girl's signal power of
knowing the positioning of all matter in
the world she'd be able to aim and
perfectly position her shot right into
the rear wheel of long-haired girl's
limo disabling the car entirely that's
assuming their car doesn't have run-on
flat tires which are tires that are
self-supporting and ones that you can
continue driving on for miles after they
are punctured if this was the case then
no worries all we'd have to do is simply
tell long-haired girl's car until their
tire finally gives out or we could
simply love tap right into them burn out
style until they simply crash and die in
a ball of beautiful flames later on at
the apartment the worst news arrives at
their doorstep economy's closest
schoolfriend has been kidnapped by the
8th clan who are holding him hostage and
if conomy wants to save him he'll have
to go find him himself we then get word
from smart girl that she's found out
where the eighth clan's base is and
where they are holding kaname's friend
and with no contact from long-haired
girl or available support from their
friends over at dangchao boxing club
kaname's group leaves to go save his
friend without any reinforcements later
they arrive at the warehouse only to
find the gang in the midst of fighting
with the police and they use this
opportunity to try and help kaname's
friend the team splits up as kaname and
machine gun guy enter the back of the
warehouse only to find conomy's friend
dead and packaged up all neatly in a box
this being the last straw konami loses
it and ends up killing the rest of the
8th clan's grunts and soldiers along
with machine gun guy ashoka defeats
dreadlocks guy using some new tricks up
her sleeve kaname had his tactics down
pat but could have used some finessing
sending a phone down to our friend to
let him join darwin's game and become
the ultimate distraction was genius but
unfortunately we couldn't do anything to
save him as he was already dead the
moment he entered that warehouse now we
know from smart girls scouting that
there are around 15 members around that
warehouse but truly i wouldn't even
concern myself with what's going on with
most of them as there's only one member
worthy enough that we should kill going
in at close range was ballsy but
unnecessary i would have ordered s'marco
to take the vantage point from the roof
as there are no guards up there and
she'll have a bird's eye view of the
whole warehouse then i'd order kaname
and machine gun guy to go in big through
the back door and create all sorts of
firepower noise with a solid distraction
in place and dreadlocks guy is surely
distracted i'd command smart girl to
fire around straight into his sweet
sweet face smart girl with her long
range and her single power means she'll
be our most accurate shooter and if we
go the ways of joe exotic and employ
some fancier looking ammunition like the
338 lapua magnum designed to penetrate 5
layers of military body armor at a
stunning 1000 meters and still be able
to kill you in the process but also i'd
probably get smart girl to equip a
muzzle break or something like that
since she's like three foot five and
this round has quite the kick with the
entirety of the eighth clan finished
kaname finally kills the human stump
called dreadlocks guy by putting a
bullet right through his gray matter as
he looks on into the distance ashamed of
his friend's death making it his mission
to find the game master of this living
hell and put an end to darwin's game
once and for all along with the help of
his new clan and now also
family
and if you're into family like this guy
then i highly suggest you subscribe for
dear life comment down below let us know
what you like what you didn't like but
before all that i want to introduce you
to our family check out the video guy al
he's a wizard
he's up there he's pretty cool check out
dom he likes pens i don't know why on
behalf of everyone from how to beat
anime thank you so much for watching our
videos and we love the support let's get
to 100 000 subscribers oh my gosh it's
so freaking exciting
let's do it see ya